[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to our next
episode of the series called language
shapes perception today we're talking
about one of the most requested topics
about uh from the language learners
and teachers
and with you is with you today is
professor s who has been dealing in
lecturing to many students about this
matter we'll discuss everything there is
to know about mother tongue and how it's
fading away
another way to call mother tongue is the
language of heart and mind
today we are all witnessing an aspect of
globalization which is the increasing
movement of people from one country to
another for different purposes
such as education desire for a better
life or the need
for employment
or even to escape from conflict between
groups including oppression of one group
by another or natural disasters
whatever the reason while such
phenomenon may have a lot of benefits
living in another country affects one's
mother tongue that's for sure
in this
episode i
strongly want to discuss why parents and
educators should support children
learning and retaining their native
language
this perspective and this research is
based on other people's
experiences and other parents
experiences
but i have often uh
traveled to other countries and i've
talked to a lot of people who have had
this
sort of concern as an esl language
teacher i have strongly encouraged my
students to develop literacy in their
mother tongue
and to take pride in their culture and
the country they originated in
every language spoken in the world
represents a special culture melody
color and acid and to everyone the
mother language is certainly one of the
most precious treasures in our lives
it's a duty and responsibility to
preserve it and to pass it down from
generation to generation whether we are
urged by necessity or because of the
some other reasons learning another
language brings a lot of advantages in
our life even though most of the time we
don't see that
or we need more time to see it
a new language opens a new window in our
world
and in our perspective and makes us more
aware or open-minded or respectful to
other cultures or lifestyles
moreover knowing another language has
been proven to contribute to helping us
understand our mother tongue better
so if you know one language and you want
to learn the second one it's way easier
if you speak more than one language so
the more languages you speak the easier
it gets
and the the easier it is to learn
the next language
however much research indicates that
most children eventually learn a second
or even more languages to a native like
fluency level
what immigrant families are not often
aware of is that many of their children
are at risk of losing their mother
tongue and this is exactly what we're
going to talk about today how to
preserve our mother tongue how to
preserve all our cultural beliefs
how to preserve our color
uh that we use every day when we speak
with with our parents with our siblings
etc
after all the language you speak is is a
color that we are all shaped uh from uh
mother language or mother tongue
also helps our emotional and mental
growth
most of the times we feel more
understood when speaking with people
that
have the same language as ours or speak
the same
language or have the same other tongue
mother languages or mother language has
a very powerful impact in the formation
of an individual
my first language
which is albanian the beautiful sounds
of which i heard and i got familiar with
before being born while in the womb and
this language has
such an important role in shaping our
thoughts and emotions
a child's psychological and personality
development will depend upon what has
been conveyed through the mother tongue
with this in mind as uh psychologists
say it matters tremendously that
language expressions and vocabulary are
chosen with care when we talk to
children
a child's first comprehension of the
world around him the learning of
concepts and skills
and his perception of existence starts
with a language that is first taught to
him which is his mother tongue
in the same manner a child expresses his
first feelings his happiness his fears
his other all sorts of emotions and his
first words through his mother tongue
mother language has such an important
role in framing or thinking emotions and
spiritual world because the most
important stage of our life which is
childhood is spent in its imprints
a strong bond between a child and his
parents especially the mother is
established by virtue of love compassion
body language and also through the most
important one which is the verbal
language we use words to communicate
even to small children
when a person speaks their mother tongue
a direct connection establishes between
heart brain and tongue or personality
character modesty shyness defects or
skills and all other hidden
characteristics become truly revealed
through the mother tongue because the
sounds of the mother tongue in the ear
and its meaning in the heart give us
trust and confidence well that's such a
powerful thing to say but i i strongly
believe that if you talk to a man in a
language he understands that goes to his
head if you talk to him in his language
that goes to his heart says nelson
mandela
i came across an interesting article in
support of the things that i just said
a study was carried out on 15 italian
interpreters who were working for the
european union and translating in
english and italian
the interpreters were all extremely
fluent in english the study revealed
surprising differences in brain activity
when the subjects were shown words in
their native language versus in other
languages they spoke
about 170 milliseconds after word was
shown the researchers recorded a peak in
electrical activity in the left side of
the brain in an area that recognizes
letters as part of words before their
meaning is interpreted these brain waves
had much higher amplitude when the word
was in italian the language the
interpreters had learned before age five
the findings show how differently the
brain absorbs and recalls languages
learned in early childhood and later in
life says ali's motto proverbial
he's a professor of cognitive
electrophysiology
at the melano-becoa university in milan
proverbial attributed the differences to
the
to the fact that the brain absorbs the
mother tongue at a time when it is also
storing early visual acoustic emotional
and other non-linguistic knowledge
this means that the native language
triggers a series of associations within
the brain that shows us an increased
electrical activity
our mother tongue is the language we use
to think dream and feel emotion
proverbial sad
another thing we can say about this uh
is that the mother tongue is an
indicator of cultural identity we show
who we are we show our culture
uh cultural identity we show where we
come from we show our history
based on the language we speak
especially when it comes to meeting
someone for the first time
they create some sort of
impression based on what you say or the
language you speak before actually
speaking to them or saying anything a
child connects to his parents family
relatives culture history identity and
religion through his mother tongue
that's for sure
native language links the child with the
culture of the society the child comes
from and shapes his identity a lot of
children from immigrant families who
don't know their native language well
are at a crossroads of identity crisis
when a child doesn't know his language
well we cannot say that he will be
nurtured was with with his culture
properly for the fact that the
relationship between language and
culture is deeply rooted so
the culture and the language are
interrelated interrelated in a way that
we can't actually separate these two
mother tongue is one of the most
powerful tools used to preserve and
convey culture and cultural ties
and
often children who are unaware of their
culture their language and their history
will lose confidence in themselves the
family society and the nation to which
they belong and will have no other
option than seeking uh
other than seeking an alternative
identity and most of the time they take
the identity of the the new country or
the new language they are using or the
country they are living in
a child will identify himself with the
language and culture he knows best for
this reason the attitudes and beliefs of
immigrant parents are so important in
this aspect
if they want to prevent this from
happening they should find ways to help
their children maintain and improve
their mother language without neglecting
to to give affirmative messages
and also to keep positive attitudes
about other cultures
we must not also forget that we live in
a multicultural society and we should
teach our children to learn about other
cultures and respect them as well
mother tongue also
provides the basis for learning another
language as i said earlier the more
languages you speak the easier it gets
to learn
your target language or your new the
next language
jim cummins also underscores the
importance of preserving mother tongue
and he says
quote unquote children who come to
school with a strong foundation in their
mother tongue develop stronger literacy
abilities in the language used at school
when parents or caregivers are able to
spend time with their children and tell
stories or discuss issues with them in a
way that develops their mother tongue
or vocabulary and concepts
children come to school well prepared to
learn language of their immigrant
country and succeed educationally the
ability to converse in a language is
developed through the mother tongue the
child will get familiarized with the
nuances of a language how to learn it
and use it and this will will also
enable him or her to learn other
languages as well
a strong foundation in their first
language will contribute to learning
another language and help them develop
stronger literacy skills in the school
language
uh because children's literacy knowledge
and abilities transfer across languages
from mother tongue to the language the
child is learning it's cool
uh that that's pretty pretty good
actually so we should definitely keep
that in mind especially when it comes to
teaching children uh
new languages when children continue to
develop their abilities in two or more
languages throughout their primary
school years they gain a deeper
understanding of language and gradually
acquire knowledge about how it can be
manipulated and applied in different
ways
children also explore the similarities
and differences between languages
but unfortunately for many bilingual
children who have little mother tongue
support at home
once they start school their mother
tongue is gradually replaced by the
majority or dominantly used language
especially in the early school years
some parents and educators believe that
in order for children to learn a second
language quickly and succeed at school
children should use the majority
language not only at school but even at
home
in fact the opposite is true children
can learn two or more languages at the
same time so that's not a problem we
shouldn't be afraid of how a child can
lose a language while learning a new one
we know that children who learn to speak
fluently two or three languages in some
countries where more than one languages
are spoken so that's a fact there are a
lot of cases
that this happens
researches show the children from
immigrant families learn the social
majority language in the early years
school very quickly although it takes
longer to learn academic language and
can lose their ability to use their
mother tongue
easily they can lose it even in the home
context if the mother languages or the
mother language is not used constantly
at home or among peers of the same
community
they may retain comprehension but will
use the majority language with siblings
friends and parents unfortunately i
often see kids from the same minority
community
speak this the majority language instead
of their mother tongue among themselves
even when they are outside of school
preferring second language to first
language most often occurs because
children do not know how to express
themselves fluently in their mother
tongue in certain contexts and
situations they lack vocabulary and
literal expressions in the mother tongue
and find it easier to express themselves
in the majority language
as children grow up parents see the
linguistic gap between them and their
children has widened and leading to an
educational disconnection
and also this educational disconnection
is also
known as an emotional
and emotional
mess
or an emotional
problem another take on this
matter is the problem
on
how to promote mother tongue
we discussed that this is an important
issue and how is how is it seen in
different concepts and different
perspectives uh but how to promote
mother tongue how to convince and how to
make students and children
use it more
how to talk about its relevance or its
importance
keeping mother tongue in a foreign
country does not happen spontaneously
that's that's definitely that's a huge
problem it's not easy but instead
it is an achievement that requires
commitment and determination especially
from the family
parents must establish a strong home
language policy and make consistent
efforts to help their children develop
good literacy skills in their first
language
there are some ideas about how parents
can promote learning
children's mother tongue or
a mother tongue the first step parents
should take is make children love mother
tongue by finding ways that motivate and
encourage its learning or to leave a
second language to the outside world and
speak to children only in your mother
tongue while at home
another way of doing that is
if we try to devote time each day to
reading and writing in mother tongue
with children until they become able to
read and write it independently
or we can try and tell stories and
discuss interesting topics such as your
childhood
which children love to hear about
parents childhoods your home country
celebrations because this will develop
both their oral and vocabulary skills or
we can
try and buy books and multimedia for
children in their
in the home language we can provide a
reward system and make learning mother
language competitive among children
watch tv series or favorite cartoons
with them in the target language or we
can also listen to song in mother tongue
children like listening to music or
children like tv series and movies so i
think that's one way of how we can use
this tool uh to
to provide them with with a good idea or
to convince them that their mother
tongue is not is not as difficult as it
seems
uh
except this we can also send children to
centers that offer courses and other
types of learning in your language for
example there are
a lot of corners like chinese corner
american corner japanese corner in many
countries around the world and in those
corners or in those centers they're
teachers who voluntarily
create or organize activities different
activities with uh
with the center of learning or
remembering or
apprecia appreciating
uh the cultural differences in in many
countries
another way of doing that uh another way
of promoting mother language is if we
provide contexts where children can use
home language such as visits to country
of origin we can organize picnics
family family trips cultural event
events or celebrations with families
from the same community
we can have them
keep journals in home language we can
have them or write about their emotions
in in their language one last thing that
we can do
to help promote uh mother language or
mother tongue
is if we communicate our expectations
about our home language to our kids
teachers and as professionals they can
encourage and support
our children or your children in keeping
and developing their home language in
many ways at school by doing projects by
creating movies creating documentaries
uh
a lot of a lot of ways the students
use these days to create projects at
school
and if you think you have other ideas or
other opinions about our topic today
please feel free to share
and
comment below thanks for listening to
languageships perception with your host
professor s i hope you enjoyed our deep
dive into this modest elaboration
if you like this episode and you're keen
to see these ideas can be applied in
your beautiful lives join us next week
when we'll be recording our next episode
tackling our next topic stay tuned as
always you can head over to our youtube
channel to sign up to our email list as
well as check out all the links and
resources in the show notes that's all
for this episode folks see you next time
[Music]